hello my name is Cil jansson I'm a
professor of epidemiology at uh the r
School of Public Health in at at emmer
University Atlanta and the title of my
talk is um predictive and not
understanding the mixed messages of our
DNA I'm going to tell in this half hour
um how it can be that DNA at the same
time is predictive for some diseases and
not predictive at all for
others I am taking questions at the end
of my talk you can write them down and
uh so we will go over them later and
please do write them down because um I
like to answer those so why we think
that genetics so that DNA is very
predictive is because we are used
already for decades um to genetic
testing for monogenic diseases um
diseases uh like familiar forms of
cancer uh breast cancer colal cancer and
several dementias also for Huntington's
disease um we know that the the genetic
mutations play a very strong role in
developing those diseases
so I here simplified it very much you
have a gene and mutations in that Gene
in some kind of pathway it's not as
simple as I present here lead to the
disease and the cause of the disease is
so strong that for example for
Huntington disease if you carry
mutations um in the Huntington Gene you
know for sure that you will develop the
disease later in life you do not know
when and how serious but you know for
sure that you're going to get it also
when you don't carry the mutations
you're sure that you don't carry uh
don't get the disease later on
and why it is so useful to do genetic
testing for those diseases is because
the risk difference between carrying and
not carrying mutation is so very huge
for for the cancers for example it makes
it sense to identify the carriers from
the general population and offer them
special intervention programs special
surveillance programs such as we have
for the familiar forms of cancer yet
there are also the current interest is
also very much on complex diseases and
complex diseases is basically the other
end of the spectrum where the genetics
is not really a major cause of the
disease it is one risk factor in a Whole
Net of other risk factors and the
environment I've summarized it here with
only one variable in my model but the
environment plays a very large role and
such a large Ro that each genetic
variant and here you see in this picture
here below you see three variants that
are implicated in type2 diabetes pmer
kab 10 and tcf7l2 they each play a minor
role in the disease you see that easily
between the risk difference difference
of between carriers and non-carriers and
comparing this graph with the one that I
presented earlier you immediately see
also why we don't do an effort to um for
example identify the carriers for P from
the general population because they have
only a slightly higher risk of type two
diabetes and the one who don't carry the
risk
variants but the idea then is is where
we think about the genetic origin of
those disease Al genetic prediction of
those complex diseases is what how
predictive can a test be when they
combine in a risk model um and the
effects of people intens two and and all
the tens maybe even hundreds now of
other type two diabetes te that we know
so far and that has got a lot of
interest in the past years and that is
the topic of my of my research so we've
become quite optimistic about the
prediction of common diseases by DNA and
that is largely due or definitely fueled
by the enormous discoveries in this
field in genetic research they have
discovered so many um susceptibility
variants that are implicated in all
these complex
diseases um and this all these
discoveries have fueled my field of
research there are numerous studies
these days in which in the research
group try to in investigate how
predictive common variants are for the
prediction of common diseases not only
genetic risk factors alone but also in
combination with non- gentic risk
factors that we have known for long
before and also we become quite
optimistic because very early on there
were already several companies who try
to sell personal genome Services via the
Internet where in using a very simple
procedure and you see that here um where
you you get a spit test uh delivered at
home you spit in it and you send it to a
lab and then 6 to eight weeks uh later
maybe even faster you get your predicted
risks for tons of diseases uh at your
computer at home this is a very simple
process and very early on I think since
2008 these companies were already
selling this but the challenge is of
course in the following what happens
between the lab test how does how do my
results get from the lab onto my
computer and here is where genetic
prediction plays a role and that uh is
is not as easy as the companies may have
suggested
earlier the what these compan is doing
and here's an example of 23m me and I
show later a slide of course that most
of you will know that they are no longer
doing this but in the past they
presenting then your results as really
for organized by by disease here are my
diseases it is my test result for which
diseases I do have an elevated risk um
for which I have an um sorry a decreased
risk or an average risk and what you see
then what they do here is for the for
disease they give me my risk and the
average risk and my risk compared to
average and um for I'm going back
shortly because here you see that for
some diseases I really have an an an
increased risk uh whereas for others the
risk is is in absolute numbers also
increased but they relative numbers not
so much now what is a shortcoming of
these tests is that for example for the
prediction of coronary heart disease
they only Bas this prediction on my
genetic risk and do not include my uh
non-genetic risk factors and that is
really a shortcoming of this uh of this
test there are many more shortcomings
and that is one of the reasons that the
FDA quite recently um I think November
last year decided to stop uh these
services from selling their products any
any longer via the Internet there's not
enough data to support that these tests
are really very
predicted uh the FDA says well we want
to this this evidence that it works in
203 says we will provide you the
evidence but we are a bit late well I
wrote recently this so in November a
piece about it in theing post that this
is not really the total story it is that
there is no evidence and both the FDA
and 23 me a bit around that fact and
there is no evidence because it is very
difficult to predict common diseases by
multiple genetic factors and here is an
example of just one study that
investigated this with not too many
Snips because otherwise it didn't fit on
my slides but this is a typical genetic
prediction studies that we'll see in the
literature um a study in 40,000
individuals where they computed a
genetic risk score for all individual
based on 10 single nucleotype
polymorphisms and these single
nucleotype polymorphisms they were
selected from from Jas studies um um
earlier on and sort of this is a bit of
a replication study in this 40,000
people they constructed the regression
model and they did that um um by
entering all the Snips as separate
variables into the model and here is
what you typically see as table one or
table two all the Snips here on the on
on the left column you see the names of
the Snips and what I always first am
interested is in the OD ratio namely
that is the the impact of that specific
snip on the risk of disease and usually
this is an alic O ratio that means that
if you have one Al of this first snip it
increases your risk of disease by
1.13 now and to me for this is already
enough information so when this um um
all these numbers are very very close to
one and it's only 10 Snips then my good
feeling immediately says that this is
not going to be very predicted and that
is then confirmed by graphs like this
that is then typically shown here you
see a risk distribution
and with on the x-axis you see the
number of risk alals for each individual
in that study uh some individuals had
less than four risk alals on those 10
Snips others more than 14 of course just
to remind you each snip you can have two
risk alals one from your father one from
your from your mother and so the maximum
number of snips that risk Al that
someone can have is 20 here you see a
range from four to 14 and what you see
here in in light gray is the risk
distribution for the controls for the
people who did not develop a disease in
that study and in Gray dark gray is the
cases and what is most important in this
graph if you really look at it from a
bit of a distance is that the risk
distribution for cases and controls
largely overlap and I will show you
later on an example where they are more
separated well when they largely overlap
it is very difficult to make a
distinction between Who develops uh the
disease and who
doesn't and that is also showing showed
in typically in an area under the RC
curve the RC curve is
um projecting for each possible
threshold that you can make with your uh
risk curve is is projecting the true
positive rate and the false positive
rate and when a test is not predictive
at all then the area the RC curve
follows a diagonal line when a test is
perfect it goes all the way in the
corner so vertically up uh along the
along the lines and here you see that
for this test the area under the curve
both in the development data set so
where they made the model as in the
replication set was only slightly better
than TOS
coin um and here you see an example what
happens when your prediction model is
has stronger predictive ability here you
see a comparable distribution like we
saw before but this is then not for
colal cancer but for type two diabetes
again the area under the curve is 60 and
when the area under the curve is 6055
distributions largely overlap here in
the right graph you see the risk
distributions when there are a few
predictors that have a strong stronger
impact of disease and for AMD AG related
micro degeneration there are a few
factors that don't increase the risk by
1.1 1.5 but really by three or five fold
and when the risk factors are that
strong you see that the risk
distributions of cases and controls
becomes more separated now why is that
important because in the in practice if
you want to use it for the prevention of
AG related marro degeneration we don't
have separate treatment for every every
score of this model no instead we have
to make a cut off score some that we say
people on the right side of the line get
treatment and people on the left side
don't get it and when your risk model is
more separated when you get the stronger
predictor it's more easy to get all the
patients or most of the patients the
people who will develop the disease on
the right side of the line and all the
people who will not develop the disease
on the left side therefore you need an
high AOC now what is a problem uh with
most of these tests these days we
largely see that risk distributions
still overlap for most of the risk
models that we are making there are
exceptions like h related micro
degeneration that I showed before but
also for celak uh celiac disease it's
also a much stronger here you see in the
left of in the right lower corner you
see an area in the curve uh how you
would like to see it where it's really
um going up to that that left corner now
what is a problem sometimes when people
make a risk model and they think it is
predictive that easily and this is the
study that I showed before that um I'm
going to show now that sometimes you see
in the news that scientists discover a
test for which they found strong
predictability here this a test what
recently in the news there was a press
release by the university itself but
when you look at the the the data of the
study that's what I'm showing here the
genetic RIS prediction uh for alcoholism
where they try to predict alcohol
dependence and alcohol abuse in several
populations I have to to discuss only
shortly they what they did here and that
is why I emphasized in a previous study
that those 10 Snips for coloral cancer
they were selected from gas here we see
that they started with 713 Snips they
could from which they could make a
selection to make a risk model they
selected the 66 that were most
predictive and made a risk score from
that well here again there two variants
one from your father one from your
mother um Range gives a theoretical
range for the snip score from 0 to 132
which for ease of interpretation they
rescale to 0 to 100 and I say this for a
reason because here are the results and
what you see with the asteris is that
the the difference between the controls
the people who who were not alcoholic
they were or did not um um have
alcoholism they are in blue and the
people with alcoholism in red and the
what you see with the aster is that the
ones in red had a significantly higher
risk score snip score than their
controls but when you look at the AES on
the YX you see that it's totally zoomed
in and it's only a difference of one
point now that is also where you see see
the the here the r curve it looks
exactly like the one that I we saw
before for cacal cancer this test the
diagonal means that the test does not
predict at all and here we see that it's
only slightly better than random
prediction um I commented on this before
too because I find it very important
that when we communicate genetic results
to the public that the public gets
really a good um representation of that
and we should not contribute with our
findings and what we want to see to
inflate expectations about what we can
do with DNA
prediction so the main problem in um in
in genetic research is is getting the
right evidence so we need to find the
right studies about predictability and
actionability but what I showed before
is also getting the evidence right you
know it's when when our results when our
studies show that the test is not so
very predictive we have to get clear
about that this is not only for common
diseases we also see that it's very
difficult to get the right evidence
where it comes to the inspitation of
monogenic diseases and we see this
discussion going on in for example in
whole genome sequencing where
researchers want to sequence um um a
person's entire genome for different
reasons but then uh you have this
discussion that they find a lot of other
um mutations that are not the ones that
they want to find but that are some what
we call incidental findings and there's
a lot of discussion on what we should do
with those in incidental findings and
the American College of medical gen last
year made a list of 55 56 genes that
definitely KN need to be returned to the
patient that should be informed to the
patient irrespective of it of their age
and whether they want to know it yes or
no because the American college find it
so important that these um factors are
when they are found then you have to
think that for example on BCA 1 and two
for breast cancer well why do I say it
in this context because also here is a
lot of discussion it is not really um
um um very clear when we should
communicate something back and when not
and it is because also uh there's a lot
of discussion about the clinical
relevance of several um mutations you
know it would be very easy when a
mutation has a strong impact on disease
risk like for example bca1 and two and
there are clear uh interventions that
you can do that you then communicate
back but the interventions are not
always clear here you see a table from a
collaboration that I um mentioned um
earlier from Jonathan Burke they publ
that in in genetics and medicines in
2013 they have a collaboration about the
return of in incidental findings and
here you see the opinions of four
participating institutes here on the
left column you see all kinds of
diseases and in the middle columns you
see whether they agree or not agree or
whether whether they think the the
mutations in those genes should be
communicated to people yes or no and
then in the right column you see all
kind of discussion about it so also it's
not clear for the common diseases but we
should um uh that we have the right
evidence yet but but also for the
monogenic diseases we still need need to
discuss a
lot so the basic question when it comes
to how predictive is our DNA uh whether
it's for common diseases or for uh for
rare diseases it always comes down to
these four simple questions um whether
DNA is predictive depends on what is
being predicted what is the disease is
it the common disease or a rare disease
in whom how so which using which genetic
variant and for what purpose that are
you when you think about prediction
research the four basic questions and
these questions one two uh one two and
three they together determine the
predictive ability so it is important to
understand that DNA does not have
predictive ability as such DNA is not
predictive or it is not predictive it
really is dependent depends on what are
you testing with genetic variant is it a
mutation is it a polymorphism is it a
copy number of variations and for which
diseases so a certain um uh um poly ISM
may be predicted for one disease but not
for
another it also sometimes vary between
populations that does not hold for
huntingon disease for example because
when you test for hunon disease in
people with a family history or um
adopted people who do not know the
family history it is very predictive but
we know for example for genes that are
implicated in obesity and diabetes that
they may uh have different effects
depending on whether people are lean or
obese that's for diabetes of course and
number question number four determines
whether the predictive ability is high
enough and it's also important to
realize there not so much to do with the
predictive ability but for example when
you think about a prediction of breast
cancer um based on single nuclear Tye
polymorphisms that might be predictive
enough to stratify a mamography
screening program um but it might not be
predictive enough to recommend a
specific wom woman uh whether she should
take PR prophylactic surgery yes or no
so a certain uh risk score might be
predicted for one goal but not for
another and this is um and I'm going to
discuss two factors that are very
important in the predictive ability of
common diseases and one fact one reason
why the predictive ability of common
diseases is not very high is that most
complex diseases are only partially
heritable um and here you see on the
right side you see a list with
heritability estimates that agree to
which the the variation in the in the
development of disease is attributable
to genetic factors you see list of
diseases and traits that vary from a
very high heritability to a very low
heritability and what does it mean it
means that even if we totally understand
the genetic background of diseases we
uncovered all the the variant that are
implicated including the interaction Etc
it means that if you use a DNA test to
predict those diseases you likely will
be very successful in predicting eye
color and type 1 diabetes the the
diseases and traes on the top but very
very unsuccessful in in happiness lung
cancer type two diabetes and the
non-familiar breast cancer simply by the
fact that non-genetic risk factors have
such a big impact on the disease risk
and that is Illustrated here by by the
picture at the left here has identical
twins who evidently do not have the same
risk for type two
diabetes another reason why um complex
diseases are so difficult to predict is
because there are many many many causal
combinations that lead to the
development of the disease and and
interestingly enough we immediately
understand that the when it happens to
disasters which are also Complex events
but we we tend to be over optimistic
when we try to um imagine the predictive
ability for common uh diseases so here
you see four ships that capsized and
four planes that crashed and I think we
all understand that these did not crash
for the same reason but also not for a
single reason and that's the same in
complex diseases an example that has
been used in um in in disaster
management that we I'm presenting
already for for quite some years
definitely since 2008 because it's so
illustrative of how how I think that
complex diseases are are finding their
CTS so this is the a of free enterprise
at capsized in 1987 um in front of the
coast of Belgium and it became a case
study in disaster management because the
ship capsized on a very clear day it was
a good ship there was nothing wrong with
the staff H everything seemed in perfect
condition and then 100 meters from the
coast at capsized killing almost 2, 200
people and they analyzed it and they
found out that there were not perfectors
together that happens approximately
simultaneously um that together caused
the capsizing of the ship and um there
are some factors that are more obvious
than the others that I showed on the
next slide but the bow doors at the back
of the ship um were open and um that is
um you see it on the on the on the left
graph you see that on the the on the
back of the ship in the red part and
that's what they also had was that the
balance tanks um were full when they
departed they have to understand that
Bast tanks you need to fill with water
when it's high tide and you need to get
cars on the deck of your ship you have
to lower the ship first and you do that
by entering water in the ballast tanks
but then before you sail off you need to
empty those ballast tanks also they were
delayed at that day and so uh they were
created they were sailing with a higher
speed than normal and what what the
higher speed does with the ship is makes
higher waves and you can feel already
what was going on these higher waves
could enter the ship because the bow
doors were open and the B because of the
batt tanks and so the ship was low on
the water if it opened bow doors the
higher WS could enter the enter the ship
and because the cars were not properly
secured on the desk they started to to
move when the water came in and the ship
capsized now this is how they summarize
that in disaster managements they make a
whyb course graph and they analyze uh
you know they break every course they
break into separate courses until it can
no further be broken down and they
concluded that the heal of the
Enterprise capsized because of a
combination of 13 risk factors
and this is also how common diseases
might occur it's it's a combination of
many many risk factors that in each of
us occur in a different combination so
it's very difficult so also for the
prediction of of common diseases um but
also for common disaster it's very
difficult to prevent common disasters
when the causal okay the causal
mechanism is every time different so the
only thing you can do it with this
information is analyze a lot of these
cap sizes and then count the number of
risk factors that intervene on the most
important risk factors and that is of
course what we are doing with with with
many common diseases in public health we
intervene on body weight on smoking on
exercise on diet
Etc and so because the common diseases
um are very complex in their origin and
only partially heritable they may not be
so uh very predictive and here in this
graph we summarize the predictive
ability of
DNA so the DN prediction by DNA depends
U uh the predictive depends on the
heritability of the disease uh and by
the genetic complexity so diseases in
the upper left corner that are very
heritable and genetically simple because
it's only one mutation or a bunch of
mutations in one gene they when we know
this genetic Origins we can do very good
prediction of disease and these diseases
we know as monogenic diseases which have
a very simple cause on the lower end of
the graph the the whole that area is the
area where the heritability is low
and when the heritability is low for
example in the in lung cancer and the
nonf familiar breast cancer and type two
diabetes then predicting diseas is based
on genetic test only will never be very
predictive because there are too many um
other factors that impact the disease
risk that are not considered in t then
on the right corner of that graph the
upper right corner is the diseases that
are very very and traits that are very
heritable but that are genetically in
the origin so complex that it's also
very difficult to predict those not
because they're not genetic enough but
but that in order to make good
prediction you need to construct a good
model and when when it's genetically too
complex it will be very difficult to
make a model that is so precise that it
can um that it can ultimately predict
very well in
individuals so this is then the the
limitations to the prediction of common
diseases now will that get better with
all the new developments that are going
on will we get better prediction of
disease when we sequence the whole
genome instead of looking only at common
variants will it get when we do larger
studies our our study is not large
enough is that a problem will we get
better prediction when we make more
complex models instead of a simple
logistic progression model and will get
better prediction when we don't not look
only at DNA but all kind of other omix F
omx parameters as well well here is my
short answer to that the question for
whether these new trends can make the
prediction better really depends on can
they increase the heritability or reduce
the complex the genetic
complexity um whole genome sequencing
may explain a larger part of the
heritability we may discover more
variants that are implicated but it does
not increase the heritability of the
diseases the same is for more complex
models um yes when we do it more
sophisticated maybe we explain a better
part of the heritability but it will not
make um the heritability um higher and
it's also not reduce the complexity and
large studies is the same thing with
whole genome sequencing we might
discover more variants but the question
is they don't they don't choose they
don't change these two parameters that
are in the graph the only thing that
does change the parameters in the graph
is considering other omic parameters
like metabolomics or um but also Imaging
parameters and why it that does change
it is because with I it it may improve
the prediction but then we are not
longer no longer looking at genetic
prediction only we are taking many many
other variables in the model and so you
can expand this graph in this way when
because heritability is just a measure
of explain variance and when your
variance gets bigger because you take
other um and explanatory variables into
the model you can move up in this graph
and maybe gets um into the green zone so
it's not very obvious that that these
new developments immediately improve the
prediction and that is because the
prediction ultimately is determined by
uh by the diseases that we are going to
predict or the traits that we are going
to predict and not So Much by our by all
the technology so here is to summarize
my talk so we have
um on one side if we if we consider this
a line from perfect prediction to very
poor prediction on one side of the line
are the monogenic diseases that we can
predict very well on the other side and
I take a very broad spectrum for that is
a common diseases that I never uh get a
very very good in
prediction then to finalize my talk so
what can we do uh can be done using DNA
what can we predict here is a list of of
outcomes that we would like to predict
with using DNA and here here's my
summary of how good we can predict them
the rare monogenic diseases yes we can
predict them very well um and the herit
disorders the syndromes we can predict
them very well because they are
genetically very simple the common
diseases I'm not so very optimistic
pharmacogenetics I leave in the middle
because uh there are some variant with
strong effect and others are uh are
smaller effects the outbreaks uh um and
the characterization of bacteria um
there's increasing research about that
it's very useful to to to characterize
bacteria and see how an an epidemic
spreads um across a region very useful
applications there forensics depends a
bit what you're doing with it it's very
useful for matching uh when you find DNA
on the crime scene and you have a
database with suspects you can match
whether that c whether that DNA is is
one of the suspects but when it comes to
prediction of eye color hair color and
length Etc is not so very predicted and
finally neogenomics that is too comp
complex to uh to discuss so when we then
look at this overview here is the two
things that we can do with it when it
comes to diagnosis and matching DNA is
very very predictive and but when it
comes to very informative let me say but
when it comes to prediction it's not so
informative at all and then here is my
final slides uh to conclude this uh this
talk um that I recently summarized in
wired the predictive ability of DNA is
limited not by technology but by the
complexity of the causes and the
heritability of the diseases traits DNA
testing might not predict diseases very
well but it can diagnose them it will
not be able to predict who's going to
commit a crime but it might help find
out who did it and it's not going to
predict who will be the best father for
a child but it can help find out who the
father is DNA might teach us more about
the past and the present than about the
future that was my talk um I'm now going
to uh see some questions and that are
raised in the by by the participants
and so one of the questions that was
asked was about the commercial uh
companies and the question was um is it
fine to go by the test reports given by
any personal zenome company in the
present scenario and then I
cannot as in Europe many companies are
still running um it depends of course on
what they are testing uh but when it is
testing for common diseases I would
definitely say no because um um we can't
predict those diseases um quite well and
most of all we also have no uh um no
evidence uh you always have to look for
what what what DNA variants are they
exactly uh testing but so far to the
best of my knowledge uh these are not
predictive enough we have recently
published a paper I did not discuss it
in this talk it's by C at all and also
on my name you can search it in genetics
and medicine that we compare the
predictive ability of of 23 a me
navigenics and Deco me and I think this
this paper you know it's only three
companies but I take them very
representative for all the others that
out are out there so I would never ever
take a medical decision based on
that the traditional clinical analysis
considered as a basic predictor for
diseases before to go to the next step
with DNA
diagnosis um that question um was asked
by Maria Dolores
sell I do not know the clinical genetics
is is not uh my uh my field of
expertise um and I do not know enough to
give an a good answer um on
this
um are all hospitals with programs that
support DNA Diagnostics for
patients is homosexuality considered for
DNA diagnosis okay that's interesting
question I would not know why you would
like to do it but that definitely
homosexuality is not that genetic that
there is a test that we can um um that
we can use it for
prediction not even close I would say um
it was in my list but I it was a list of
diseases and traits and not all the
traits in the list were diseases but
it's it's it is like alcoholism and like
also about suicide risk what was
recently in the news those traits are so
complex there are so many factors
involved that we can never diagnose that
or icted reliably on based on
DNA um hospitals with program that
support DNA diagnosis there are mostly
indeed for patients uh you need to have
an indication generally to get uh to get
into
there is personalized genomics a good
approach for clinicians to consider um
that is a question by Arun Kiran Pam and
I would like to challenge you to refine
what you consider with personalized
genomics because that is a very um um
very broad broad term if you think about
the the the personal genome services
like those offered by by 22 me I would
definitely not do
it um and I think for everything that is
personalized and genomics these days we
do not have yet sufficient
evidence would I use DNA to predict
Sports
Performance um I can give a cynical
answer here uh to Anna sandal I can also
give my true answer no and my cynical
answer is uh um if you want to be fooled
yes but but that's not uh that's not a a
good answer no also sport performance
those um uh trades depend so much uh on
so many other variables that it's very
difficult to use a DNA test to even say
whether you are more likely to become a
sprinter or a endurance
Sporter um I think you know these these
kind of test for sport performance for
homosexuality for suicide risk for
alcoholism that has all been in the
media but there is an an an enormously
wide difference because between what is
reported in the media and what we find
evidence in science and um I think with
everything every trait or every disease
that has many many risk factors involved
um it is very unlikely that a DNA test
will be a very good
predictor and with that I answered my
last uh question and I thank you all for
your uh for your
attendance